I've been fascinated with savants
mathematical savants and there was a guy
I was I was looking at young guy 12 year
old from United States called Jacob Jake
Barnett actually he did this thing on 60
minutes where he visualized numbers well
six looked like six that's like the edge
points of that so in this report
Jacob Jake Barnett was showing how much
of a genius he is and he actually showed
a way that he visualizes numbers that's
different I've never seen it before and
the reporter didn't go into any detail
he just said and this is how he sees 54
but that wasn't enough for me because I
downloaded to the HD download 1080p and
I wanted to see it so I blew it up and
just with that information just that
picture and the number I worked out what
he'd done this is when I do basic stuff
this is 2 times 27 also known as 54
let's start with the number 3 how did
you visualize 3 here it is huh so why
attach why's it a triangle Brady because
it tells our three sides but he's not
interested in the sides Brady he's
interested in the points so 1 2 3 now
that's really important what about 3
times 2 so 3 times 2 is 6 so you might
think 3 times 2 6 hexagons okay but no
and there's a reason why is because the
hexagons 6 6 is not a prime number so
primes are important to mathematicians
so he wants to keep the primes so now he
wants to keep it so he does he actually
puts a triangle on top of another
triangle 1 2 3 4 5 6 so let's keep going
what about 3 times 3 all right so again
he starts with a triangle happens to be
red I don't know whether that was
important enough 3 times 3 he doesn't
put 3 triangles on top of one another no
no no 3 times 3
it's triangles high ends so that's why
the ends the vertices are important so
we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 that's 9 okay next time what we're
going to do is we're going to try times
3 again so now we've got 3 times 3 times
3 9 3 is 27
you should cotton on to how he does this
now he puts triangles on the edges check
that out
triangle triangle triangle triangle so
now that's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 18 27 but
the reason why I understood this is
because this is called what is doing is
is prime decomposition so the fact is
the integers the whole numbers you can
write any whole number in its atomic
form which is primes this is like
factorization exactly this is 2 times 27
also known as 54 so this is for the 60
minutes report 2 times 3 times 3 times 3
ok so this is what he did if it's this
times 2 that's pretty obviously what
needs to happen you need to go huh and
then you need to back and then you need
to go so that's it
that's 54 there's 54 points so what's
really good about this better than just
having 54 is the fact that you can look
into the number which is pretty cool
because you can look at it and if you're
shown a number you can go oh I know I
know what this number contains it
contains 3 divisible by 3 not once
because there's another smaller triangle
so it's a visible way 3 by 3 and there's
another smaller triangle again so it's
divisible by 3 by 3 by 3 so it's like an
x-ray the only problem is you don't know
what the number is just by looking at
readily like I could put my pin number
down and I think that'd be quite safe
unless you paused it and worked it out
but if I just flashed it you wouldn't
know what it is I don't know how it
helps him I think the the thing I got
out of it was the fact that this here's
someone who's not afraid to reimagine
mathematics because we get taught maths
a certain way we got we get taught maths
a specific way base 10 based on the fact
that we've got these okay and and that's
not math that's just one way of seeing
that and so this is great because it's
like it's intuitive it's it's
imaginative he's come up with it his own
way sure this is like I saw the link to
like what we'd say is like you know
accepted mathematics prime factorization
of integers accepted way but I mean this
is wonderful and for me I got to kind of
try and understand this kid the savant
who's going to go on and do amazing
things he's going to do amazing things
and look here he is taking what we get
taught at school and having fun with it
thanks to the great courses plus for
supporting this video if you fancy
enjoying your very own online university
why not check out this treasure trove of
lectures and lessons from world-class
professors there are thousands and
thousands of videos covering all topics
from history to photography we'll learn
some of the mathematics behind the
Rubik's Cube and well you won't be
surprised to know that some of my
favorites are the ones about mathematics
and numbers just this week I've been
watching one called the joy of primes
and I've learned a few new things I
really recommend it plans for the great
courses plus start at 14.99 a month but
you can start a free one-month trial by
going to the great courses plus comm
slash numberphile there's the address on
the screen the great courses plus comm
slash numberphile or you can click on
the link in the video description no
tests no homework watch at your own pace
and our thanks to them for supporting
this video